one of the things you may not have
noticed or that maybe you noticed not
noticing is that none of these suppose
that fiscal conservatives are asking how
would we pay for the war in Iran and
we've been talking for a decade on this
issue about the political football that
is the deficit and our national debt and
as we often say we never have money for
health care we never have money for
education but we always seem to have
money for war and for missiles and for
contracts for defense contractors and
all of that stuff and it's happening now
is happening front and center right now
and as horrible as the Iran situation is
I do believe that it can be instructive
on a few levels we already talked about
how the propagandizing around Iran is
very reminiscent of 2000 to 2003 Iraq
the linking Soleimani to 9/11 much like
Saddam wasn't linked to 9/11 is another
example of that and so there's really a
lot to learn from this as we panic and
try to prevent Donald Trump from
starting another war over the last year
we've seen the debate about healthcare
explode single-payer health care
proposals of different kinds have been
put forward Medicare for all a very
prominent example of a single-payer
health care program and you have a lot
of people on the right and left because
the left always cares about how much
things cost we just have answers for
those questions there has been a
question of how much will Medicare for
all cost well what where will we save
and where will we need new money and how
much do we spend per person now what
would we spend under Medicare for all
what's the additional cost versus what
we're already spending what kind of a
payroll tax would we need on employees
and employers to get it all to balance
out so on and so forth these are all
very good questions which the left and
me personally we like to think about
this with anything that government does
on the right you see a lot of concern
trolling around the costs because they
only care about the cost when it's
something that they don't want to pay
for and then you see Donald Trump for
political reasons to take attention away
from his impeachment
to try to get himself reelected because
he believes it will help is starting to
try to escalate with Iran with a
political assassination and no
Republicans other than the lone
libertarian here are they're saying wait
a second guys can we afford this can we
spend all this money on a war with Iran
which would would likely cost trillions
of dollars how much will this cost where
are we going to get the money how many
lives will be lost where are we going to
pull money from and it can be very easy
to forget when there is not a drive to
war that the entire right-wing fiscal
concern trolling is merely that its
concern trolling they do not really care
about the spending as long as it's
spending on things they like . i tweeted
yesterday quote but how would we pay for
the war in Iran what about the deficit
through the numbers balance and there
were some very interesting replies
including doesn't matter it fits the
neoconservative worldview to concur
absolutely correct this is never
actually about money it's about they
don't like Medicare for all and they
like attacking countries another tweet
pointing out a similar idea which said
cuts and social programs education
health care increased military budget
and an even bigger deficit you can't put
a price on freedom meaning election wars
cost a lot
they cost lives and then I was also glad
to see one person actually used the term
concern trolling and their reply to me
saying quote it's almost as if the hand
wringing and pearl clutching over
budgets and deficits when it comes to
anything beneficial to the general
population is just concern trolling that
is absolutely correct if you're
wondering how do we pay for all of the
social programs that we want look at
Donald Trump's own tweet where he said
quote the United States just spent two
trillion dollars on military equipment
we are the biggest and by far the best
in the world there's the cash for your
social programs it's a sick reality that
we are leave living in but I hope you
know any any of the future calls that
I'm going
you get about but but David how much is
this going to how much will it cost to
make sure nobody goes hungry how much
will it cost to make sure no one has a
medical bankruptcy where are you right
now and why aren't you asking that
question about what's going on in Iran
what if I told you that you could read
eight books in one afternoon
that's essentially what one of my
favorite apps allows you to do it's
called blinka stand you can try it
totally free for a week and get 25% off
a subscription when you go to blink east
comm slash Pakman blink Asst takes
thousands of best-selling non-fiction
books gathers the most important info
and insights from each book presents
each book to you in the form of a
condensed ebook or audio book that you
can consume in just fifteen minutes
there are only so many hours in your
week blinka snakes it possible for you
to absorb the most valuable takeaways
from non-fiction books that you
otherwise might not have a chance to
read I just finished listening to the
way we eat now by Bea Wilson whose work
I've recommended to you before super
interesting look at how the global food
system works and impacts the way that we
live you can use blink Asst to get
through a topic quickly and efficiently
it's really useful if you just want to
explore a certain topic but don't
necessarily want to commit to reading
the entire book about whatever it is and
a premium subscription is only about
eight bucks a month which gives you
unlimited access to every single book
that they offer they have books on
politics economics philosophy science
you name it you can try it out yourself
totally free for a week and get 25% off
if you decide to subscribe just by going
to blink as comm slash Pakman I've put
the link right underneath this video